.
* Dubiose Klänge *
Menschenhandel findet statt.
In der Schweiz gibt es Frauen,
die nicht freiwillig hier sind,
die gezwungen werden, ausgebeutet
werden und Gewalt erleben.
Sex ist mittlerweile
für wenig Geld zu haben.
Die Prostituierten kommen fast alle
aus Nigeria oder Osteuropa.
Ich war eine Weile in Italien.
Dann hat mich jemand
in die Schweiz gebracht
und mich
an seine Kontakte weitergegeben.
Das war's. Von da an
habe ich auf der Strasse gearbeitet.
Die Armut in Nigeria ist der Grund,
warum so viele Menschen
dieses Land verzweifelt verlassen.
Menschenhändlerbanden aus Afrika
breiten sich seit Jahren
in der Schweiz und ganz Europa aus.
Mehr als drei Viertel
der Prostituierten
machen ihren Job nicht freiwillig.
Was wir hier in Zürich
an der Langstrasse sehen,
ist nigerianische
organisierte Kriminalität,
das ist ein Milliardengeschäft
weltweit.
Die Methoden im Business
werden immer brutaler.
Du kannst nicht weglaufen oder
dich verstecken, die kriegen dich.
Nigerianische Netzwerke
verdienen Milliarden
mit der Zwangsprostitution in Europa.
Das ist Sklaverei,
weil die Opfer von Menschenhandel
von Nigeria bis sie in Europa sind
ausgebeutet werden.
Sie müssen 60'000-80'000 Euro
zurückzahlen.
Die Spuren der Menschenhändler
führen von der Langstrasse
zu den Drahtziehern im Ausland.
Jedes Jahr schleusen sie
Tausende Frauen nach Europa ein,
um die Nachfrage nach billigem Sex
zu bedienen.
Ich bin ein Mensch, ich habe Angst.
* Unstete Musik *
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Die A3 auf der Höhe der Raststätte
Mumpf im Kanton Aargau.
Hier ist eine Frau
im vergangenen Winter
vor Menschenhändlern geflüchtet.
(Mann) Polizeinotruf,
grüezi, Herr Graser.
Wie die Frau zu Protokoll gab,
hätte sie nach Deutschland
verschoben werden sollen in
einem Van, mit vier anderen Frauen.
Sie witterte ihre Chance
bei einem Halt an der Raststätte,
flüchtete vor ihren Aufpassern,
die immer präsent waren,
und kam die Böschung runter
zur Hauptstrasse.
Dort sah sie den Autofahrer
und hielt ihn an.
Die 32-jährige Frau
kommt aus Westafrika.
Sie sagte, sie sei Prostituierte
gewesen, festgehalten worden.
Wir haben sie unterdessen
detailliert befragt
und nehmen an,
dass das so gewesen sein muss.
Wir müssen annehmen,
dass sie etwa ein halbes Jahr
an einem Ort festgehalten und der
Prostitution zugeführt worden ist.
Es wurde ihr eine Stelle als
Altenpflegerin in Aussicht gestellt.
Sie hatte ein komisches Gefühl,
aber dachte, sie steige ein.
Sie konnte die nötigen Formalitäten
abwickeln mit Mittelsmännern.
Die brachten sie
per Flugzeug nach Athen.
Von dort ging es weiter nach Genf
und dort merkte sie,
dass sie in etwas anderes
reingeraten war.
Die Frau ist eine von wenigen,
die die Flucht vor
den Menschenhändlern gewagt haben.
Die Dunkelziffer, schätzt man,
ist hoch.
Polizeiliche Ermittlungen
haben bisher nichts ergeben.
Die Frau konnte
keine genaueren Angaben machen.
Peter Bächer ist Chef der Ermitt-
lungsabteilung Strukturkriminalität
bei der Kantonspolizei Zürich
und weiss, wie schwierig
Ermittlungen in diesen Fällen sind.
Gerade bei den Westafrikanerinnen
haben wir festgestellt,
dass die nicht mal wissen,
in welchem Land sie sind.
Aus polizeilicher Sicht
ist extrem wichtig,
dass die Erstausrücker, die
mit den Frauen konfrontiert sind,
die Merkmale erkennen,
dass das ein Opfer sein könnte,
richtig handeln und die Frau
zu einer Opferhilfestelle
oder an einen geeigneten Ort
bringen.
Im konkreten Fall
hat die Polizei sofort reagiert
und die Frau in den Schutzräumen
des Fraueninformationszentrums FIZ
untergebracht.
Das FIZ bietet Migrantinnen Hilfe an,
die von Gewalt und Ausbeutung
betroffen sind.
Die FIZ betreut,
begleitet und berät jährlich
rund 400 Betroffene
von Menschenhandel.
Davon sind ca. zehn Personen
aus Nigeria.
Wir sehen aber auch, dass Personen
aus anderen Ländern bei uns sind,
z.B. aus Uganda, die
sehr ähnliche Geschichten erzählen
wie die Betroffenen aus Nigeria.
Bisher gab es allerdings
keine Verurteilungen,
obwohl die Polizei weiss,
dass die Menschenhändler
in der Schweiz sehr aktiv sind.
Gerade im Bereich der Westafrikaner
stellen wir fest,
dass die Gegenseiten, Täter
und Opfer, extrem volatil sind.
D.h.,
wir kontrollieren heute jemanden,
der ist morgen in Biel, in Lausanne,
in Konstanz oder in Lyon.
Das geht so schnell.
Die sind nicht ortsgebunden und
reagieren sehr schnell auf Druck.
Bei dieser Gegenseite
müssen wir gut vernetzt arbeiten,
sowohl national
als auch international.
Der ehemalige Journalist Stephan
Fuchs recherchiert seit Jahren
die Hintergründe von
westafrikanischen Menschenhändlern
und arbeitet eng
mit der Polizei zusammen.
Die Italiener
haben die nigerianische Kriminalität
als fünfte Mafiaorganisation
definiert.
In der Schweiz ist man da
noch einen Schritt zurück,
man konnte das
noch nicht so klassifizieren.
Etwa ein Fünftel der Männer
in der Schweiz
nimmt regelmässig
sexuelle Dienstleistungen in Anspruch
und lässt sich das nach Schätzungen
jährlich
gesamthaft etwa 3,5 Mrd. Fr. kosten.
Sex mit Zwangsprostituierten
ist zwar strafbar,
doch Verstösse
können kaum verfolgt werden.
Einerseits, wenn man Freier
zur Rechenschaft ziehen wollte,
stellen sie sich auf den Standpunkt,
nicht gewusst zu haben,
dass sie mit einer
Zwangsprostituierten Kontakt hatten.
Andererseits fehlt uns
die ausdrückliche Rechtsgrundlage,
die man in Nordeuropa z.B. hat,
wo Freier wirklich zur Rechenschaft
gezogen werden können.
In Schweden setzt die Polizei
verdeckte Ermittlerinnen
als Prostituierte ein,
um Freier zu überführen.
In Zürich, schätzt man, prostituieren
sich rund 1'500 Frauen täglich.
Etwa 80-150 kommen aus Nigeria.
Seit 25 Jahren betreibt Cornelia
Zürrer in der Nähe der Langstrasse
ein Nachtcafé der Heilsarmee,
wo sich die Frauen treffen können.
Zwangsprostitution aus Nigeria
ist für sie nichts Neues.
Es ist etwa 12, 13 Jahre her.
Da kamen sie zum ersten Mal
zu uns ins Nachtcafé.
Es war am Anfang sehr schwierig,
irgendetwas über sie rauszufinden,
weil sie eigentlich
gar nichts Persönliches sagten.
Wann immer es
um ihre Situation ging,
wie sie hier wohnen, woher sie
kommen, blockten sie gleich ab.
Sonst waren sie sehr herzlich und
sehr zugewandt, aber da kam nichts.
Wir fanden heraus, dass viele von
Italien oder Spanien gekommen waren,
weil sie eben auch Italienisch und
Spanisch sprachen, nebst Englisch.
Also war klar, dass sie
länger dort gewesen sein mussten.
Wir fanden bei den meisten raus,
dass sie dort schon in
der Prostitution arbeiten mussten.
Viele haben Kinder zu Hause
in Nigeria, haben Familie,
aber sonst kam am Anfang gar nichts.
Es ist nach wie vor schwierig,
an die Frauen heranzukommen.
Sie werden in ganz Europa
herumgeschoben.
Deutschland
kämpft mit dem gleichen Problem.
ZDF-Journalist Jan-Philipp Scholz
recherchiert im Internet
und kommt so auf die Spur
einer jungen Nigerianerin.
Sie lebt in Süddeutschland und hat
in verschiedenen europäischen Ländern
als Prostituierte gearbeitet -
jetzt will sie aussteigen.
Seitdem ist ihr Leben in Gefahr,
sagt sie.
Lange zögert sie.
Schliesslich
ist sie aber doch bereit,
sich mit Jan-Philipp zu treffen.
Blessing
ist nicht ihr richtiger Name.
Das ist das erste Mal, dass ich
jemandem meine Geschichte erzähle.
Seitdem das alles passiert ist, habe
ich wirklich Angst, riesige Angst.
Ich bekomme viele Anrufe -
von deutschen Nummern,
von italienischen Nummern,
sogar französische Nummern
rufen mich an.
Ich erhalte viele Drohungen:
Wenn ich der Polizei oder irgend-
jemandem in Europa etwas erzähle,
werde ich sterben.
Ich habe niemanden,
mit dem ich reden kann.
Wenn meine Eltern aus Afrika
anrufen, v.a. meine Mutter,
kann ich ihnen nicht davon erzählen,
was ich hier durchmache.
All die Dinge, die ich erlebe.
Das ist hart, das macht mich kaputt.
Blessing
ist bei Bekannten untergekommen
und versucht,
alle Kontakte ins Milieu abzubrechen.
Die Vergangenheit
lässt sie trotzdem nicht los.
Es war schrecklich.
Um 9 Uhr abends
mussten wir aus dem Haus,
den Bus nehmen, zur Arbeit fahren.
Manchmal hatte ich vielleicht vier,
manchmal fünf Männer.
Manchmal sogar mehr.
Manchmal auch nur zwei.
Die ganze Zeit war mir klar,
dass dies nicht das Leben ist,
das ich mir erhofft hatte.
Aber ich hatte keine Wahl,
ich musste es tun.
Ich habe einen Schwur geleistet:
Sie haben meine Schamhaare,
meine Unterhose,
meine Fingernägel und mein Blut.
Blut von meiner Zunge.
All diese Dinge
können sie gegen mich verwenden.
Der Voodoo-Priester
hat die komplette Macht über mich.
Martialische Voodoo-Rituale,
auch Juju genannt,
sind eine gängige Methode
der Menschenhändler,
um junge Frauen aus Westafrika
gefügig zu machen.
* Klappern *
In einer angsteinflössenden Zeremonie
wird den Opfern klargemacht,
dass sie die Forderungen
der Menschenhändler befolgen müssen.
Ihnen wird gedroht,
dass ihnen und ihren Familien
etwas Schlimmes passiert, sollten sie
sich nicht die Abmachung halten.
Voodoo ist Voodoo.
Ich bin ein Mensch, ich habe Angst.
Es ist ein Konzept,
das sie aus ihrem Heimatland kennen.
Viele dieser Frauen
sind sehr gläubig.
Und das passt in dieses Konzept
des Glaubens rein.
Mit diesem Schwur
hat man sie z.T. sehr im Griff
und löst eine grosse Angst aus.
Es gibt gewisse Narben, Markie-
rungen, die wir z.T. gesehen haben.
Wenn sie z.B. bei uns im Büro
Kleider anprobieren, sieht man es.
Es gibt einige wenige,
die etwas andeuten,
aber sie reden eigentlich
nicht über das.
Jan-Philipp Scholz' Recherchen
führen in die bayerische Provinz.
Blessing hat ihm
die Drohbotschaften weitergeschickt.
Ein ehemaliges Mitglied
einer nigerianischen
Antimenschenhandels-Taskforce
soll sie auswerten.
Nach massiven Drohungen im Heimatland
ist der Mann nach Deutschland ge-
flüchtet und hat hier Asyl beantragt.
Kannst du dir die Nachricht anhören
und mir übersetzen, was sie sagt?
Das ist eine Madame, die
über eines ihrer Mädchen spricht.
Es hört sich so an, als ob
das Mädchen nicht mehr zahlen will.
Sie sagt:
"Ich werde den Boys Bescheid geben,
dass sie sich
um sie kümmern sollen."
Die Jungs haben bereits ihr Foto.
Sie werden sie kriegen,
sie wird nicht entkommen.
Der Informant erklärt,
wie nigerianische Menschenhändler
normalerweise vorgehen.
Das Leben des Mädchens
hängt komplett von der Madame ab.
Die Boys werden alles
mit ihr machen, was die Madame sagt.
In Nigeria werden die jungen Frauen
von einer sog. Madame -
einer Art weiblichen Zuhälterin -
und ihren Komplizen
mit falschen Versprechungen
angelockt.
Einen Teil der Kosten
für die Schlepper legt die Madame aus
und fordert später
ein Vielfaches zurück.
Durch einen Juju-Priester werden die
Frauen zusätzlich eingeschüchtert.
In Europa übt ein komplexes,
mafiaähnliches Netzwerk
Kontrolle über die Frauen aus.
Sog. Boys machen die Opfer gefügig -
oft auch mithilfe von Gewalt -
und treiben das Geld ein.
Aussteigerinnen
können den Netzwerken kaum entkommen,
da auch ihre Familien in der Heimat
unter Druck gesetzt werden.
In Zürich hat Stephan Fuchs
über Facebook den Menschenhändler
Jeffrey ausfindig gemacht.
Dieser war sofort bereit,
eine Reise für zwei fiktive Frauen
von Nigeria aus zu organisieren.
Unser Ziel war nicht,
die Frauen physisch zu verschieben.
Wir wollten an die Hintergrundinfor-
mationen von diesem Jeffrey kommen.
D.h., wir konnten oder wollten
dieses Spiel so lange treiben,
bis er uns die Bankdaten angab
für die erste Transaktion,
die wir hätten ausführen sollen.
Aufgrund davon konnten wir
die Madame und die Bankkonten
identifizieren.
Es gibt natürlich
verschiedene Fluchtwege nach Europa
von Nigeria aus.
Der typische beginnt in Edo State
und geht zur ersten Etappe in Kano,
das ist im nördlichen Nigeria.
Von da aus ist die nächste Etappe
Agadez in Niger,
und von da aus
geht es mit dem Toyota-Pick-up
über die Wüste nach Libyen
bis nach Sabha.
Das ist die erste grosse Stadt,
wo es auch
sog. Connection-Häuser gibt.
Menschenhändler Jeffrey am Telefon:
Zwischenhalt für die meisten
sind Connection-Häuser in Sabha.
Ein Connection House
ist ein sicheres Haus,
wo die Frauen ankommen,
wo sie arbeiten,
wo sie ihre Prostitution
dort in Libyen schon ausüben,
wo sie bewacht werden,
von wo aus sie nachher
auch weitergebracht werden.
Das kann innerhalb weniger Wochen,
aber auch mehrerer Monate sein -
bis sie das Reisegeld
wieder angeschafft haben,
um weiterreisen zu können.
Sie werden dort
z.T. zu Tode geprügelt,
sie werden dort vergewaltigt,
aber auch in Europa
haben wir Hinweise darauf -
es gibt Videoaufnahmen und Bilder,
die solche Massregelungen zeigen.
Auch Jeffrey droht, als er merkt,
dass etwas nicht stimmt.
Sabha ist nur ein Zwischenhalt.
Von dort aus geht es dann
an die Küste und dort wartet man,
bis die Boote nach Italien
bereit sind.
Dort werden sie sich bereits das
erste Mal in Europa prostituieren.
Ein wichtiger Ausgangspunkt,
den wir gesehen haben,
ist Brescia in Italien, Norditalien
generell, aber auch Frankreich,
von wo sie
nach ganz Europa verschoben werden.
An der Langstrasse
bleiben sie vielleicht
zwei Wochen, höchstens zwei Monate.
* Rätselhafte Musik *
Da konzentrieren sie sich
auf zwei bis drei Häuser,
wo viele zusammenleben.
Ich denke, sie sind unter Kontrolle.
Allgemein gesehen -
sie dürfen sich schon frei bewegen,
aber die Frauen
haben uns z.T. gesagt:
"Die Kontrolle
ist da oben in meinem Kopf."
Sie werden unter Druck gesetzt
mit ihren Kindern in Nigeria.
Man sagt ihnen:
"Wenn du nicht jeden Monat zahlst,
passiert deinem Kind,
deiner Familie etwas."
Sie sind in schwierigen Situationen.
Julia
ist eine der wenigen, die reden.
Die Nigerianerin war selbst
Zwangsprostituierte in Zürich.
Jetzt arbeitet sie
mit der Polizei zusammen.
Ich bin mit dem Flüchtlingsboot
nach Europa gekommen.
Sie haben uns gerettet
und an Land gebracht.
Dann hat mich jemand
in die Schweiz gebracht
und mich an seine Kontakte
weitergegeben - das war's.
Von da an
habe ich auf der Strasse gearbeitet.
Mithilfe einer Opferorganisation
schaffte Julia den Absprung.
Nun will sie Stephan Fuchs zeigen,
wie die Frauen hier leben.
Mein Boss
hat nicht in der Schweiz gelebt.
Einige von denen haben Angst vor Eu-
ropa, aber sie haben immer jemanden,
der dich beobachtet
und das Geld eintreibt.
Julia wird mit einem versteckten
Aufnahmegerät ausgestattet,
um die Aktion mit Stephan Fuchs
zusammen verdeckt zu filmen.
Ein bisschen Sorgen
mache ich mir schon.
Aber es ist wichtig,
dass die Welt sieht,
in welchen Verhältnissen
diese Frauen leben.
Vielleicht kann ich sie dazu
bringen, sich mir anzuvertrauen.
Sie haben immer Angst
vor der Polizei,
aber bei einer Afrikanerin werden
sie sicherlich keine Bedenken haben.
Julia macht sich auf den Weg
an die Langstrasse.
Eine nigerianische Prostituierte ist
bereit, sie zu einem Hotel zu führen,
in dem sie mit anderen afrikanischen
Frauen ein Zimmer teilen muss.
Die Zustände sind schockierend:
Auf vier Etagen hausen hier
mehr als 40 Prostituierte.
An den Wänden schimmelt es,
es stinkt nach Fäkalien.
Und das mitten in Zürich,
wenige Kilometer von
der noblen Bahnhofstrasse entfernt.
Wir machen das, weil wir
keine andere Möglichkeit haben,
um Geld zu verdienen.
Ich brauche Geld.
Was ist denn passiert?
Meine Madame hat mich geschlagen.
Ich glaube,
das muss behandelt werden.
Könnt ihr mir helfen?
Wenig später
müssen sie den Dreh abbrechen.
Sie werden gewarnt, dass Aufpasser
über ihre Anwesenheit
informiert worden sind.
Am nächsten Tag wertet Stephan Fuchs
die Bilder mit Julia aus.
Trotz des abrupten Abbruchs
bringt die Aktion neue Erkenntnisse.
Ein Trend, den die beiden erkennen:
Die Frauen werden immer jünger.
Das ist schockierend: Zwei von den
Frauen gestern wirkten ganz zart.
Die taten mir besonders leid,
als ich sie sah.
Wie zerbrechlich sie wirkten.
Offenbar müssen
auch Mädchen unter 18 anschaffen.
Ja, klar,
sie bringen auch Minderjährige.
Das grösste Problem sei,
dass die Opfer ein falsches Bild
von Europa hätten, findet Julia.
Ich glaube,
in Nigeria wissen viele nicht,
dass die Menschen hier
ein solches Leben führen müssen.
Sie können sich das
nicht vorstellen:
So viele Leute auf engem Raum.
Es ist wie ein Sklavenleben.
Und es gibt viele Menschen
in ganz Europa, die so leben.
In Frankreich, in Deutschland, in
der Schweiz, in Italien - überall.
Gegen die Zustände
in den Zimmern an der Langstrasse
können die Behörden nichts tun.
Und mehr Razzien,
wie z.T. politisch gefordert wird,
bringen selbst
aus der Sicht der Polizei nichts.
Da bin ich sehr ambivalent.
Wir würden
den Druck auf die Opfer erhöhen.
Die Gegenseite
reagiert sehr schnell.
Wenn wir eine Razzia machen,
müssen wir damit rechnen,
dass die Frauen, wenn wir
von sexueller Ausbeutung sprechen,
sehr schnell weg sind, an
einen anderen Ort gebracht werden,
nicht mal in der Schweiz, vielleicht
nach Spanien oder Italien.
Damit
wären auch mögliche Zeuginnen weg,
und die Chance noch kleiner,
an die Hintermänner heranzukommen.
In dieser Frage sind sich
die Polizei und das FIZ einig.
Gerade auf dem Platz Zürich macht
die Polizei einen sehr guten Job.
Es gibt eine spezialisierte Polizei
auf kantonaler Ebene,
es gibt Milieuaufklärung
auf städtischer Ebene.
Es wird wirklich hingeschaut.
Natürlich könnte es immer
mehr Ressourcen geben,
mehr Personen
könnten noch besser hinschauen,
aber es wird einiges gemacht.
Obwohl die Polizei den Fokus
v.a. auch auf die Hintermänner legt,
sind die Frauen nicht bereit,
auszusagen.
Cornelia Zürrer betreut
die Prostituierten an der Langstrasse
schon seit 25 Jahren.
Hoi.
- Ciao. Wie geht's?
Gut. Und dir?
Noch nie hat sie erlebt, dass eine
gegen ihre Peiniger ausgesagt hätte.
Sie haben Angst.
V.a., solange sie noch abzahlen,
ist das extrem schwierig.
Kürzlich hatte ich bei einer
das erste Mal das Gefühl,
dass sie nahe dran ist, in ein Ver-
fahren, in die Opferhilfe zu gehen.
Sie war in Kontakt mit der FIZ,
der Fachstelle Frauenhandel,
hatte schon ein Gespräch gehabt.
Schlussendlich
entschied sie sich doch dagegen.
Ich denke, der Punkt war
einerseits die Frage:
"Bin ich da sicher? Bin ich sicher?"
"Ich muss noch abzahlen,
wie zahle ich jetzt ab?"
"Ich muss abzahlen, ich kann
nicht einfach aufhören, abzuzahlen."
"Ich bekomme vermutlich
eh keinen Status hier."
Diese Perspektive können wir ihnen
aktuell mit dem Migrationsregime,
das existiert, nicht bieten.
Die Personen aus Drittstaaten -
und Nigeria ist ein Drittstaat -
können nicht legal
nach Europa migrieren,
sie können also auch nicht legal
in Europa arbeiten.
D.h.,
sie sind auf jemanden angewiesen,
der ihnen den illegalisierten Weg
ermöglicht.
Das bringt sie in eine Schuld,
die sie nachher ausbeutbar macht.
Die meisten nigerianischen Frauen
sind mit Touristenvisa da.
Doch es flüchten auch
immer mehr Opfer von Menschenhandel
aus umliegenden Ländern
in die Schweiz.
Sie stellen hier ein Asylgesuch,
obwohl sie
nicht auf Hilfe hoffen können.
Aktuell haben wir
eine Lücke im Opferhilfegesetz.
Personen, die im Ausland
von Menschenhandel betroffen sind,
werden aktuell in der Schweiz
aufgrund des Opferhilfegesetzes
nicht geschützt,
obwohl das die europäische
Konvention eigentlich vorsieht.
Wir haben da wirklich
eine Lücke im Gesetz.
Wir sind aktuell daran, zusammen mit
anderen Akteurinnen in der Politik,
diese Lücke bei der Opferhilfe
zu schliessen.
Ein Vorstoss, das Opferhilfegesetz
auf Opfer
aus dem Ausland auszudehnen,
die hier einen Asylantrag stellen,
ist im Parlament hängig.
Doch Stephan Fuchs bezweifelt,
dass er mehrheitsfähig ist.
Ich persönlich befürchte,
dass es einen Opfertourismus
auslöst, dass man das missbraucht.
Darum bin ich diesem Ansatz
gegenüber relativ kritisch.
Ich fände es v.a. wichtig,
die Opfergesetze,
die in der Schweiz vorherrschen,
richtig und konsequent umzusetzen,
bevor man ausländische Opfer
auch noch aufnehmen kann.
Politisch
dürfte es tatsächlich schwierig sein,
das Opferhilfegesetz
auch auf die im Ausland
von Menschenhandel betroffenen Frauen
in der Schweiz anzuwenden.
Die Sozialdirektoren der Kantone
schlagen nun einen Kompromiss vor.
Wir sagen,
es braucht eine pragmatische Lösung.
Im Vordergrund steht nicht
eine Entschädigung oder Genugtuung,
sondern die Unterstützung der Opfer
in der Bewältigung dessen,
was sie erlebt haben.
Dafür haben wir vorgeschlagen, eine
Case-Management-Stelle einzurichten,
von Bund und Kantonen zusammen -
eine Art Kompetenzzentrum,
das bei einem Verdacht
die aufwendigen Abklärungen macht
und dann dafür sorgt, dass die Opfer
Zugang haben zu den Leistungen,
die sie brauchen, d.h. zur spezifi-
schen Beratung durch die Opferhilfe,
zu Übersetzungsleistungen
und auch zu Schutzunterkünften,
wenn sie das brauchen.
Im Moment haben wir für das alles
keine rechtliche Grundlage.
D.h., das ist im Moment
nicht bezahlt.
Es geht jedoch
nicht nur um Opferschutz,
sondern v.a. auch darum,
die Hintermänner der
afrikanischen Netzwerke zu kriegen.
Um das zu erreichen, hat die Polizei
die Ermittlungen interkantonal
und national intensiviert.
Wir haben eine nationale Plattform,
die Arbeitsgruppe Menschenhandel
und Menschenschmuggel.
Das ist
eine polizeiliche Arbeitsgruppe,
in der wir Good oder Best Practices
austauschen.
Da sind alle Kantone mit am Tisch.
Aber im Kontext Menschenhandel
im Bereich Nigeria
haben wir einen sehr intensiven
Austausch mit fedpol.
Ich habe mehrmals wöchentlich
Kontakt mit den Kollegen in Bern.
Ich glaube,
wir sind da auf gutem Weg,
dass wir schnell und international
vernetzt, das ist wesentlich,
einen Schritt vorwärts machen können
in nächster Zeit.
Auch mit Stephan Fuchs ist
die Polizei regelmässig in Kontakt.
Er hat verschiedene Puzzlestücke
zusammengefügt, um zu verstehen,
was das System der Ausbeutung
aufrechterhält.
Oft sind sog. Geheimbünde involviert.
Die Netzwerke
sind sehr straff organisiert.
Es gibt einen Head
und verschiedenen Positionen -
von der Wirtschaftsabteilung
bis zur Informationsabteilung.
Es gibt auch einen sog. Butcher,
der Massregelungen macht,
wenn Mitglieder
aus der Reihe tanzen.
Diese nigerianischen Geheimbünde
stellen Europas Sicherheitsbehörden
schon länger vor grosse Probleme.
Bereits 2019
warnte auch der Bundes-
nachrichtendienst vor den Gruppen.
Über Spanien und Italien würden sie
immer weiter
nach West- und Zentraleuropa drängen.
Damals
standen v.a. zwei Kulte im Fokus:
die Black Axe,
zu Deutsch "Schwarze Axt",
und die Supreme Eiye Confraternity.
Inzwischen kamen weitere Namen hinzu,
unter ihnen die Vikings,
die Maphite und die Jurists.
Sie alle haben in den letzten Jahren
in zahlreichen europäischen Ländern
ihre Netzwerke aufgebaut.
Bei der Bundespolizei verfolgt man
ihre Strukturen und Machenschaften
schon seit 20 Jahren.
Diese Bruderschaften
entstanden in den 1960er-Jahren
als Studentenverbindungen
in Nigeria.
In den 70er-Jahren wurden sie
von der Regierung verboten.
Da gingen sie in den Untergrund
und begannen,
kriminelle Aktivitäten zu entfalten,
um sich weiterzuentwickeln
und zu überleben.
Sie wurden aktiv im Menschenhandel
und in der Prostitution
und stiegen in den Drogenhandel ein,
in Europa und auf der ganzen Welt.
So sichern sie sich
ihr Weiterbestehen.
Die Bruderschaften kontrollieren die
Frauen oft auf der gesamten Route:
vom Transport durch Afrika über die
Flüchtlingsboote auf dem Mittelmeer
bis hin zum Zielort in Europa.
Auch nach vielen Jahren
Beschäftigung mit dem Thema
ist für Stephan Fuchs verblüffend,
wie viel Geld mit dem Leid der Frauen
in der Schweiz verdient wird.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass wir
auf der Langstrasse in Zürich
rund 150 nigerianische Prostituierte
haben, die pro Tag ...
... drei Klienten haben,
und die bezahlen sehr wahrscheinlich
etwa 40 Fr. pro Job.
Das ergibt täglich
18'000 Fr. Umsatz.
Wenn man das hochrechnet
auf ein Jahr,
gibt das satte 6,5 Mio Fr. ...
... die umgesetzt werden
in Zürich an der Langstrasse.
Nur einen kleinen Teil
dürfen die Frauen behalten.
Der Rest wird durch ein illegales
System nach Nigeria verschoben.
Die Bruderschaften
sind über die Grenzen vernetzt.
Besonders das sog. Hawala-System
machen sie sich zunutze.
Das Hawala-Banking ist ein
uraltes System zur Geldüberweisung.
Es funktioniert eigentlich gleich
wie Western Union.
Sie geht zu einer Vertrauensperson,
übergibt ihr das Geld
in einem Laden,
bekommt dafür einen Code
und diesen Code gibt sie einem
Geldempfänger in Nigeria bekannt.
Der Geldempfänger
geht auch in einen Laden,
zeigt den Code und bekommt damit
das Geld ausbezahlt.
Die Hawala-Banker gleichen ihre
Schulden durch gegenseitige Transfers
oder den Schmuggel von Schmuck, Gold
oder Luxusautos immer wieder aus.
Was den Menschenhändlern beim Waschen
ihres schmutzigen Geldes hilft:
In den meisten Ländern Europas kann
man immer noch vieles cash bezahlen.
Autos werden hier gekauft und in
Nigeria mit Gewinn wieder verkauft,
so wäscht sich das Geld.
Zurück in Deutschland.
Auch Blessing
musste ihre gesamten Einkünfte
an einen Geldeintreiber abgeben.
Einen festen Preis gibt es nicht.
Man muss einfach Geld anschaffen.
Selbst, wenn jemand
nur 10 Euro für Sex zahlen will,
lässt du dich manchmal darauf ein -
nur, um Geld präsentieren zu können.
Natürlich muss man alles abgeben,
nichts davon kannst du behalten.
Du kannst auch nichts verstecken. Du
wirst am ganzen Körper durchsucht.
Blessing schuldet den Menschen-
händlern angeblich 35'000 Euro.
Von den Freiern erhält sie
durchschnittlich 30 Euro.
Davon werden ihr
diverse Nebenkosten abgezogen.
Die übrigen 15 Euro
dienen der Schuldentilgung.
Pro Tag muss Blessing
etwa drei bis fünf Freier bedienen.
Sie verdient also
durchschnittlich 120 Euro,
kann davon aber
nur 60 Euro zur Tilgung einsetzen.
Der Rest
geht direkt an die Menschenhändler.
So müsste Blessing etwa 2'300-mal mit
fremden Männern bezahlten Sex haben,
um ihre Schulden
komplett zu begleichen.
Jan-Philipp Scholz
versucht, über den Weg des Geldes
mehr über die Hintermänner
zu erfahren,
die Blessing in die Schuldenfalle
lockten und bedrohten.
In Frankfurt
trifft er den Informanten wieder.
Er zeigt ihm Videomaterial von
einem mutmasslichen Geldeintreiber.
(Aufnahme) Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nimm das bloss nicht
auf die leichte Schulter.
Wir werden dich umbringen.
Er sagt: "Wenn ich dich sehe,
werde ich dich
mit einer Pistole erschiessen."
Er droht offenbar damit,
jemanden zu töten?
Ja, und er droht
nicht nur der Person selbst,
sondern der ganzen Familie.
Selber glaubt man vielleicht,
dass man sich verstecken kann.
Aber die ganze Familie
kann sich ja nicht verstecken.
Das ist beängstigend, oder?
Ja, verdammt beängstigend.
Und das sind keine Spielchen,
die meinen so etwas ernst.
Kannst du verstehen,
dass sich Opfer von Menschenhandel
davon einschüchtern lassen?
Natürlich, und nicht nur die Opfer.
Es gibt Leute in der Regierung -
Leute, die diese Sachen bekämpfen
sollten -, die Angst haben.
Polizisten haben Angst vor denen.
Das ist kein Spiel,
das ist verdammt ernst.
Jan-Philipp Scholz verfolgt den Weg
des Geldes weiter bis nach Nigeria.
Er sucht eine Frau, die auch in
Blessings Fall verwickelt sein soll.
Am Flughafen
trifft Scholz Solomon Okoduwa.
Dieser leitet eine Organisation,
die sich um die Aufklärung
von Menschenhandelsfällen kümmert.
Die Polizei
ist hier selten eine Hilfe.
Okoduwa hat schon einen Zeugen iden-
tifiziert: einen Bruder von Blessing.
Dieser
hat wahrscheinlich Informationen,
die Scholz
zu der Frau führen könnten.
Er hat Angst.
Wir haben es schliesslich
mit einer Art Kartell zu tun.
Die Frau wirkt auf den ersten Blick
vielleicht ganz sanftmütig.
Diese Madames sehen oft überhaupt
nicht furchteinflössend aus,
aber sie haben
ein mächtiges Netzwerk hinter sich,
und manchmal
reicht da ein einziger Anruf.
Benin City ist eine
der gefährlichsten Städte Nigerias.
Mehr als 80 % der nigerianischen
Menschenhandelsopfer
kommen aus dieser Region.
Zudem ist die Stadt eines der Zentren
von Nigerias Schattenwirtschaft,
berüchtigt für seine Hawala-Agenten,
Hinterhof-Banker und Geldwäscher.
Scholz trifft Blessings Bruder
in einem armen Vorort der Stadt.
Dieser ist nervös.
Wir alle in der Familie
hatten keine Ahnung,
dass meine Schwester
nach Europa wollte.
Später erzählte sie uns, dass ihr
eine Frau dabei geholfen hatte.
Sie hätte vorher mit jemanden
von uns darüber sprechen sollen.
Seit sie 2019 weggegangen ist,
haben wir nur Ärger hier.
Diese Frau
hat Schläger auf uns angesetzt.
Sie haben uns
schon mehrmals hier bedroht.
Erst letzte Woche
kamen wieder acht Männer vorbei.
Sie wollten offenbar
meinen Vater töten.
Gott sei Dank war er nicht zu Hause.
Ich beobachtete alles
aus einem Versteck.
Sie hinterliessen eine Notiz.
Auf dem Zettel stand,
wenn meine Schwester die Schulden
bei der Madame nicht abbezahlt,
werden sie meinen Vater töten.
Seitdem sind schon wieder
neue Drohungen gekommen.
Wir schlafen kaum noch - irgendwann
werden sie bestimmt ernst machen.
Solomon kann Festus überzeugen, seine
Informationen mit ihm zu teilen,
und versucht, bei der Polizei mehr
über die Angreifer herauszufinden.
Während sie warten, erzählt er,
dass der Menschenhandel in der Region
immer brutaler wird.
Die Folgen der Pandemie
treiben viele Nigerianer ins Ausland.
Und die Macht der Netzwerke
sei inzwischen so gross,
dass sie den Zusammenhalt
ganzer Familien zerstöre.
Wenn die Mutter eines Opfers
von diesen Gruppierungen
ins Visier genommen wird
und solch massiven Drohungen
ausgesetzt ist,
sagt sie ihrer Tochter in der Regel:
"Mach, was immer sie dir sagen!"
"Wenn du dich prostituieren musst,
dann prostituiere dich eben."
"Schau einfach,
dass du das Geld abbezahlt bekommst
und dass wir hier in Nigeria
in Frieden leben können."
Solomon hat neue Informationen.
Eine der identifizierten Personen
passt genau zur Beschreibung
der Frau, die Scholz sucht.
Sie wurde laut Polizei
bereits mehrfach beschuldigt,
Menschenhandelsopfer zu bedrohen,
und baut gerade in einem der besten
Stadtteile Benin Citys ein Haus.
Die Polizei entscheidet, die Verdäch-
tige zu einem Verhör einzubestellen.
Angeblich hält sie sich
gerade auf ihrer Baustelle auf.
Die Frau wurde gesichtet,
deshalb müssen wir sofort handeln.
Lass uns hoffen,
dass die bald keinem Opfer in Europa
und keinen Familien mehr
das Leben zur Hölle machen kann.
Glaubst du, das ist realistisch?
- Ich hoffe schon.
Mit einer guten Zusammenarbeit
der Sicherheitsbehörden
und mit Gottes Hilfe
werden wir Erfolg haben.
Someone's running. Shall we get out?
Die verdächtige Baustelle.
Hier entsteht eine typische
Vorstadtvilla, vermutlich finanziert
durch die Ausbeutung
von Blessing und anderen Frauen.
Vor dem Haus:
eine höfliche, gut gekleidete Dame.
Sie lässt sich ohne Diskussionen
mit aufs Präsidium nehmen.
Nicht selten waren Madames
früher selbst Prostituierte
und haben sich im Laufe der Jahre
mit Intelligenz und Skrupellosigkeit
hochgearbeitet.
Wir werden jetzt
umfangreiche Ermittlungen anstellen.
Dann werden wir sehen,
inwieweit sie involviert ist.
Aber es gibt Hinweise?
Ja, in diesem Fall
und auch in zwei weiteren Fällen,
wo Mädchen
nach Dubai geschickt wurden.
Das Haus wurde also wahrscheinlich
mit Geldern aus dem Menschenhandel
gebaut?- Ja, Menschenhandelsgeld.
Optimistisch scheint die Ermittlerin
nicht zu sein.
Wenn wir feststellen,
dass es Beziehungen
zu Leuten in der Behörde gibt,
ziehen wir uns aus dem Fall zurück.
Das kann gefährlich werden,
das habe ich schon selbst erlebt.
D.h., sie haben vielleicht
mächtige Freunde?
Ja, sie können dann wirklich
Menschen auflauern und auch töten.
Wenn wir also merken,
dass es irgendwelche Verbindungen
zwischen Menschenhändlern
und staatlichen Stellen gibt,
wird uns das zu heiss.
Eine Ermittlerin, die offen erzählt,
dass Verfahren eingestellt werden,
wenn Verdächtige gute Kontakte haben.
Das Geld aus der Zwangsprostitution
scheint diesen Ort
zu einem quasi gesetzlosen Raum
zu machen.
Am nächsten Tag
erneut ein Treffen mit Solomon.
Auch er scheint trotz des Erfolgs
nicht zufrieden zu sein.
Die Verdächtige sei wahrscheinlich
Teil eines viel grösseren Netzwerks.
Die Bereitschaft der Behörden,
so schnell zu handeln Ð
für Solomon hat sie auch
mit der Anwesenheit
eines Fernsehteams zu tun.
Sie haben Verbindungsleute
in allen Sicherheitsbehörden.
Diese Typen arbeiten sogar
direkt mit den Madames zusammen.
Wir hatten vor Kurzem ein Opfer,
das mit dem Pass einer anderen
Person nach Dubai reiste.
So etwas ist nur möglich,
wenn hohe Sicherheitsbeamte
an den Flughäfen involviert sind.
Okoduwa ist überzeugt:
Die Profiteure des Menschenhandels
sitzen überall
an den Schalthebeln der Macht.
Scholz reist weiter nach Lagos,
in die Wirtschaftsmetropole Nigerias.
Hier lebt
ein Grossteil der Elite des Landes.
Sie stellt ihren Reichtum
gerne zur Schau,
während weit mehr als die Hälfte der
Nigerianer in absoluter Armut lebt.
Investigativjournalist
Nichola Ibekwe
beschäftigt sich seit Jahren
mit den Verbindungen
zwischen der politischen Elite
und der organisierten Kriminalität.
Für ihn ist klar:
Nigeria hat sich durch die Macht
der kriminellen Netzwerke
zu einer Art Mafiastaat entwickelt.
Natürlich gibt es Korruption
überall auf der Welt.
Aber der Unterschied zwischen Nige-
ria und einem Land wie Schweden ist:
Dort werden Gesetze befolgt
und es entstehen keine Räume
der Straflosigkeit.
Hier ist das so:
Wenn du gute Beziehungen hast,
geben sie dir einfach einen Klaps
auf die Hand und lassen dich laufen.
Ibekwe hat dem schmutzigen Geld
der nigerianischen Elite
mit Undercover-Aktionen nachgespürt.
Sein Fazit:
Oft führen die Spuren des Geldes
auf verstecktem Weg
wieder zurück nach Europa.
So wie es aussieht, ist London
der Lieblingsort dieser Elite,
aber sie kaufen Eigentum
in allen Ecken Europas.
Es gibt Berater,
die sich darauf spezialisiert haben.
Sie übernehmen die ganzen
finanziellen Abläufe für dich.
Sie helfen dir dabei,
Scheinfirmen zu gründen,
und erledigen alles Weitere.
Es geht immer
um den politischen Willen.
Ich glaube, die ganze internationale
Politik und Diplomatie
sind v.a. Heuchelei.
Die Spuren des schmutzigen Geldes
führen also ironischerweise dorthin
zurück, wo sie begonnen haben:
nach Europa, auch an die Langstrasse.
Zum grossen Teil wird das Geld
schon in Nigeria investiert.
Wir haben aber neu auch gesehen,
dass das Geld schon in der Schweiz
und in Europa investiert wird
in Form von Immobilien, von Discos,
von Produktionen im Bereich DJ.
Diese Reinvestments in der Schweiz
hat die Bundeskriminalpolizei in Bern
durchaus im Visier.
Diese Dinge sind auch Teil
der Strategie follow the money
von fedpol und Europol.
Das Ziel ist, nicht nur die Täter,
sondern auch das Geld zu verfolgen
und die Werte einzuziehen,
die durch die kriminellen Handlungen
erwirtschaftet werden.
Für uns ist das ein wichtiger Zweig
im Kampf
gegen die organisierte Kriminalität.
Ansetzen für eine wirksame Bekämpfung
müsste man nach Meinung
von Stephan Fuchs aber auch dort,
wo man am ehesten zu verwendbaren
Zeugenaussagen für Verfahren kommt:
bei den betroffenen Frauen.
Bei den nigerianischen Netzwerken
kommt man dann weiter,
wenn man den Frauen Sicherheit des
finanziellen Gewinns bieten kann,
also dass sie legal arbeiten können
in der Schweiz.
Sicher auch,
indem man ihnen die Angst nimmt,
dass sie erkannt werden
von ihren Netzwerken.
Drittens, auch ein wichtiger Punkt:
dass sie
in Sicherheit aussagen können.
Das alles kann die Schweiz
bisher nicht garantieren.
Darum ist es auch verständlich,
dass die Frauen nicht aussagen.
Der Teufelskreis dreht sich weiter.
Die Schweiz hätte es in der Hand
und könnte handeln,
die Schweiz
könnte diesen Selbsteintritt machen.
Ja, man muss davon ausgehen,
dass es politisch so gewollt ist,
dass man das nicht macht.
Andere europäische Staaten
machen das.
Auch für Blessing ist
der Albtraum nicht zu Ende.
Die mutmassliche Menschenhändlerin in
Nigeria ist wieder auf freiem Fuss,
Blessing hat neue Drohungen bekommen
und einen Abschiebungsentscheid
der Ausländerbehörde.
Trotzdem
träumt sie nach wie vor davon,
irgendwann in Deutschland
eine Chance zu bekommen.
Ich bin aus Nigeria weg,
weil ich ein besseres Leben wollte.
Wenn du in Deutschland zur Schule
gehst und dich an Regeln hältst,
kannst du die Person werden,
die du gerne sein möchtest.
Du brauchst keine guten Beziehungen.
Ich möchte einfach die Sprache
lernen und einen guten Job bekommen,
vielleicht in einem Krankenhaus.
Wenn Frauen wie Blessing in
der Schweiz legal arbeiten könnten,
wären sie nicht mehr erpressbar,
sagt Cornelia Zürrer.
Sie versteht nicht,
warum man hier wegschaut.
Für die Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine
hat man relativ schnell
den S-Status aktiviert,
damit sie hier
leben und arbeiten können,
weil man weiss,
dass sie alle gefährdet sind.
Bei diesen Frauen aus Nigeria
weiss man, dass die Allermeisten
Opfer von Menschenhandel sind,
und sie bekommen keinen Status.
Warum kann man da
keine solche Lösung schaffen?
Um an die Täter heranzukommen,
wäre aber auch ein verstärkter Fokus
der internationalen Polizeiarbeit auf
die nigerianischen Netzwerke nötig.
INTERPOL hat das vor Kurzem angeregt
und die Schweizer Ermittlungsbehörden
haben den Handlungsbedarf
offenbar ebenfalls erkannt.
Wir kennen die Initiative von
INTERPOL und sind daran beteiligt,
wir haben unser Interesse
deutlich gemacht.
Heute ist es noch zu früh,
um darüber zu sprechen,
aber wir sind effektiv
Teil dieses Prozesses.
Das klingt gut, doch Cornelia Zürrer
ist nach all den Jahren
an der Langstrasse desillusioniert.
Jedes Mal, wenn das Problem in
den letzten Jahren öffentlich wurde,
hat sie bisher das Gleiche erlebt.
Es ist gut, dass man aufklärt.
Andererseits gibt das Druck auf die
Politik und die Verantwortlichen.
Die wollen schnell etwas machen,
und dann wälzt man den Druck ab
auf die direkt Betroffenen.
Ehrlich gesagt, hat es ihnen
bisher mehr geschadet als genützt.
Man müsste tragbare,
langfristige Lösungen suchen,
statt einem Schnellschuss,
der wieder mehr Kontrollen bedeutet
und dass man sie einfach nach
Italien oder Spanien zurückschafft.
Zwangsprostitution und Menschenhandel
sind grausamer Alltag
für Tausende Frauen in Europa
und die Behörden können
den afrikanischen Mafianetzwerken
bisher noch keine wirklich
wirksame Strategie entgegensetzen.
Ändern könnte sich das nur,
wenn die Freier, die das Geschäft
ankurbeln, bereit wären,
auf die Dienstleistungen
dieser Prostituierten zu verzichten.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Martina Riedi - 2023